while the GOP candidates get ready to
square off in Iowa the Biden campaign is
getting hit with another left hook by
team Obama former aids for Barack Obama
are talking some serious trash on Joe
Biden's floundering reelection strategy
one Democrat telling Politico how ex
Obama AIDS think the president's
campaign ground game is a dumpster fire
quote the vibe was that the campaign
didn't have its bleep together there was
an infrastructure in the states there
wasn't a beefed up Campaign Headquarters
and compared to where Obama was in 2011
the campaign was fairly anemic but who
needs a ground game when you have dark
Brandon top Biden campaign staffers
telling Jens saki about their ridiculous
plan to save Joe this is a guy who uh
loves talking to people uh and
campaigning require more than most
people more than most people certainly
more than me and is he game for all the
digital proposals you're putting forward
oh absolutely all the sort of dark
Brandon jokes and videos you've seen
he's he's leaning right into them but
Bernie Sanders says voters especially
young ones are not buying it this choice
is pretty clear running against Donald
Trump who I suspect will be the
Republican candidate is one of the most
dangerous political figures in modern
American history so I think people will
end up routing around Biden but there is
no question it is very hard for young
people I think for most Americans to be
excited about what is going on right now
president has got to change
course all right Jesse polls show Biden
at his lowest
numbers uh 33% approval rating and 28%
think he has a mental acuity to go
forward yet the Biden people as you just
heard seem to be ignoring that believing
that all they need to do is lay out the
stakes well Biden won because of covid
they didn't produce a record amount of
Voters they produced a record amount of
ballots and then everybody sat around
for four months in their houses and
apartments while the ballots got
harvested that's how they won this time
they're going to have to actually get
their base to the polls or get their
base to request ballots everybody knows
it takes a lot of organization and
passion and Biden's base realizes
they're in a toxic relationship now the
dark Brandon memes don't slap these
things have been dormant for eight
months every time I hear about dark
Brandon I think of trump hitting him in
the head with a golf ball while he falls
up the stairs of Force One this guy is
losing every single voter that came out
for him the last time and if I were the
Obama team I'd be worried too and now
he's complaining about the media for not
doing a good enough job these guys wrote
articles that said inflation was good
they wrote articles that said Bush was
selling nuclear secrets to the Saudis in
the patio of Mara Lago he should be
bribing the Press instead of bribing
college
kids all right uh Dana or actually I'll
give this to Jessica Jessica what makes
the the Biden people think that they can
actually butt heads with the Obama
people who believe that Barack Obama in
2012 had the most successful reelection
blueprint for presidency in
history I wouldn't say that they think
that they can butt heads with them but
they do have a good record to run on in
terms of winning elections Jesse say
what he wants about 2020 we know Joe
Biden as president then Democrats went
on to win the midterms shocked everyone
right the red wave that didn't happen um
and we've done super well on all of the
ballot referendums that have been going
on all over the country especially in
conservative States fueled by gen Z
voter turnout so young people seem to be
liking Democrats fine the Obama people
know what they're talking about about
the ground game we're here in Iowa where
Barack Obama became an a sensation and
shocked everyone when he won Iowa in uh
2008 and you can learn a thing or two
from them but for instance the
fundraising numbers came out today Joe
Biden 97 million taken in in Q4 117
million on hand his team is outpacing
what the Obama campaign had did in 2011
so at the end exactly this period in
time but in 2011 97% are Grassroots
donations I've heard oh well that's you
know Hunter Biden's friends in Ukraine
or in China that are sending that money
over no it's regular people that want to
support Joe Biden for president um and
if you look at the real clear politics
average uh Donald Trump is up by 1
percentage point now um in the average
of the polls so doesn't seem that bad
within the margin of error it's going to
be close but the Biden campaign has a
lot to be proud of all right Dana you
know there is still a growing divide
within the Democrat Party that Joe Biden
seems to be out of step with Americans
not just Young Americans not just black
Americans not just minorities but just
about everybody yeah I have a great
respect for what the Obama team was able
to do not just the first time when they
won in 2008 but when they won
re-election in 2012 but I think their
attacks on Joe Biden are getting a
little tired and that it's actually
getting to the point of being rude at
this point chirping from the sidelines
about how bad they think the campaign is
it's not helpful to Joe Biden and if
they really want to help him then maybe
like stop talking about it in the press
and suit up show up and see if you can
help them you know the the the race in
2012 is not the same one as in 2024
there's so many different factors as to
the Jens saki interview with the Biden
campaign staffers who think that they're
online social media presence is going to
beat president Trump's when he gets
going have you seen the meme game that
President Trump's campaign has had
against Ronda santis it has been vicious
and it's been funny I don't know if the
Biden campaign is prepared for that kind
of energy to turn onto them I don't
think that they'll at this point could
even possibly match it all right Greg
you want to wrap it up sure I love the
sacki and those two young Consultants
pretending that that dark Brandon is a
thing the only thing dark about Brandon
are his boxers it is like that when I
looked at that I swear I thought that
was a Babylon B video because it was
just like they you could just see them
lying to themselves there is this belief
or hope that all you need to do is apply
the magic of Obama Campaign onto Joe's
but there's something missing there
Obama you know with him you had a highly
competent Lucid campaigner you don't
have that here you have a scarecrow held
together with wine this is like telling
a runner in your local 5K Turkey Trot
you know just imitate Usain Bolt and
you'll win no it only works for Usain
Bolt the Democratic party right now is
like a used car lot and and Joe is a is
a barely running tradein they just need
to get him off the Lots you know apply
some new paint you know on the test
drive Turn up the radio so you don't
hear the the engine knocking and don't
go over 25 or the hub caps will fall off
this the Dems and Republicans have an
awesome opposite problem Biden is too
weak to fix Trump is too strong to
influence so Republicans have to accept
that you're going to have to let Trump
be Trump because he doesn't change and
dams have to be like well I got this
empty bucket and we have to fill it how
are we going to fill this empty bucket
you can't let Joe be Joe because that
scares the hell out of the voters we saw
him wandering around in that store in
Pennsylvania it was like he was looking
for that bright light he was supposed to
walk toward so I think uh it it's a
serious problem hi everyone I'm Brian
killme I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now